The Joe Rogan experience,
but there was a guy that we've made fun of a bunch on the show who was, uh,
a pastor to a lot of famous people. He was like the hip young pastor.
We just got busted, just got busted, banging some chick. Yeah.
And we made fun of him because I'm like, look, there's this guys.
There's no way this guy's religious. This is what I was saying,
because he was wearing these shorts that showed what I called his Dick root.
Like he wears these shorts that go way low,
which you just don't wear your shorts like that.
Unless you want someone to think about your penis, right? Like that's,
that's why you wear your shorts like that maybe in the seventies. But I mean,
I'm not,
there's no reason to gotcha guys who wear their shorts that low right there.
They're being overtly sexual to people, but they don't even necessarily know.
Right. You're trying to, and you want everyone to look at your chiseled body,
you know, like this is none of the,
there's a reason why monks dress in these like very modest clothes that
cover everything. They don't even want to think about their body. Right. And,
um, that is a part of the religion of both celebrity
and social media, right.
That this guy has got these traditional Christian ideas
fused in with the religion of celebrity in with the religion of
social media. And then you're seeing that it doesn't really work because,
you know, like what, what's the reward for those, those behaviors,
the reward is he wants to like that guy wants people to,
that guy wants people to lust after him. And, uh, it,
it wound up sabotaging him.
Absolutely. Ultimately, absolutely. Um, I think, yeah, it's a,
it's an Allah morality story of some kind of rural sale. You know, this is a,
uh, kind of, um,
celebrity fame kind of pursuing the trick goes wrong.
It's a trap because if you achieve, like, what do you, what if you're,
you're lusting after this, uh,
this attention and this sexual praise and he want people to
last after you,
you also want them to think of you as being someone who is more enlightened than
everyone else,
which is why you're willing to stand in front of them and give these
emotional,
profound sermons in the first place that resonates with all these lost young
people.
Well, right. And historically there's, um,
a lot of overlap between sort of celebrity and, um,
religious preaching people like Billy Sunday, or sure. You know, others that,
you know, th that that's the,
the religious leader becomes a celebrity and those lines get blurred.
And it all becomes entertainment, which yup.
For celebrities,
there's a need for that because they feel very lost and disconnected because
they've achieved the thing that they've always desired and they still feel lost.
Like everyone's looks at certain celebrities and then go, Oh, my you've made it.
Your life must be heaven and they're depressed and all up.
And we don't have any sympathy for them. Right.
There's no one that's going to be sympathy sympathetic to Justin Bieber with no
$300 million in the bank and having sex with anybody who wants to like,
you for being depressed. He's a little piece of.
You've been famous your whole life. But for him,
it's probably very confusing because first of all,
particularly like the really young people who became famous while they were
young, like I had Miley Cyrus on who I think is incredibly talented,
brilliant, brilliantly, talented. Her voice is fantastic. I mean, so soulful,
but she got famous when she was 12. I have a 12 year old man.
I can't even imagine.
I can't imagine being the boss and filling arenas when you're
12 it's madness. Right. And no one survives it. Right. They don't, I mean,
maybe a few have gotten through it and they're saying right,
but most of them don't, and that's where celebrity preachers come in,
where someone can harness your,
your celebrity and it boosts them up. And they can also provide you.
Maybe even maybe if it's disingenuous,
but some sort of a structure that makes you feel like there's more
that you, that you can,
you can cling to something that's going to make sense of this all.
And that's something is Jesus, right. Or Muhammad or whatever it is,
whatever it is that you, you cling to whatever structure that you cling to.
Right. Buddha, whatever it is. Right.
And that can be exploited, especially in those situations.
I think because of what you were saying, a gap or absence, you know,
Oh God, I got here and you know, is this all there is.
With the children in particular because there's not, Oh God, I got there. It's,
I've never been normal.
Well, that, especially, it's like.
Having cement, but you've never added water. Right. Like it's never,
there's something missing. Yeah. Well, you didn't grow up. Right.
And on many of them don't, they don't survive, survive. And, and, uh,
yeah. Obviously drugs can be a one way to,
it's the most common way to, to deal. Yeah. You know, try to try to deal.
Yeah.
I'm, I'm, I'm well aware of a lot of people, uh, in,
in the whole Hollywood show business world that grew up famous and
almost none of them survive. Yeah. Yeah. Rob Lowe did though,
Rob Lowe got famous, real young. He's super normal.
He might be like one of the only ones I've ever met and I've hung out with him.
Right. And I've hung out also more importantly with him and his son.
Who's also really normal and really well adjusted,
but he also got clean and sober. Right.
Right, right, right. Yeah. So yeah. I mean, he made it, he made it,
but very few.
It's also very beautiful. Yeah. It's probably easy to be Rob Lowe. Right.
Imagine he's gotta be what, he's 40, 30. No, he's older.
That he's older than me. I'm 53. I believe Rob is 45. Yeah. Okay.
Well anyway, there you go.
He's one of the few that got famous very young and has navigated it
through with grace. But, uh,
I think the ones that are children that grow up child stars, the,
you know, the ones on Mickey mouse show and that kind of. Good luck.
No, I mean that's.
So they find the celebrity preachers. This is often what happens.
They find gurus, they find celebrity preachers. Right, right. Yeah.
Someone who tries to make sense of things for them.
What do we look forward to, to put our faith in? You know, and,
and that's that they're there too is a pretty common universal, um, uh,
aspect of human life is in the product. I have something to believe in.
Poor gurus. They fall into the trap too,
because now they can leech off the success of these famous people and become
famous themselves. Right. And maybe they haven't really
immunized themselves and not related themselves to the power
of celebrity. Sure. It's a very intoxicating drug.
Like you got to understand how to, how to avoid it. Right.
And avoid the pitfalls of it. It's not easy. Yeah.
Yeah. Well, again, that's,
that's the life that everyone wants. I mean, that's,
that's part of the pressure I assume. Um, for a lot of people is just, you know,
the, the American public,
the global audiences are going to be transfixed on, on, on,
you know, and also, you know, want what you have, but.
We can really learn from those, those preachers,
those preachers that only go after the like, really like, not,
not only go after, but, uh, attract celebrities.
Like there's something to that weird sort of parasitic genre
of, you know, of preacher.
Right? No, I agree. I think it's right for study. There's been any kinds of,
um, well certainly, I mean, we've seen that, well, I'm sticking to drugs, man,
for now. I don't want to go, well, everybody's a drug intoxication.
Now this is sort of what we're after it takes some form.
Celebrity. I think there's a drug and soul.
There there's several drugs that are mixed together and sort of a concoction.
There's a drug of celebrity, which, uh, you know, for sure is a drug.
And then there's also a drug at being the person who has the answers.
Definitely.
And there's something that people do when they convince other people that they
have the answers that it elevates their mood and their
perspective. That's like some weird guru drug. Yeah.
So there's the guru drug. And then there's the celebrity drug.
We're Nate, we're identifying a whole nexus of.
And would that guy was the sex drug? Cause he's a beautiful man.
He's a handsome, tall ripped shredded.
Right, right, right. A lot of drugs going on there. Well,
and I wonder how extensive it all was extensive. Well, in terms of his,
you know, whatever of activities he was engaged in the God-man. Yeah.
And I think with people like, then this is where it's,
I'm going to give a simplistic perspective. I think he could have, uh,
benefited from real drugs.
So I think a person who's involved in those three weird drugs could have been
they've really, really good.
Have benefited from psychedelics because psychedelics would have let you say,
Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, do you see what you're doing?
Because I see what you're doing. Right. Like a dog. So it's an,
I know what you're doing. You're pretending you're pretending to be profound.
You're pretending to be pious. You're pretending to be enlightened.
You're pretending to be above it all, but you're not, no,
you're just one of us. Right.
It can be, uh, pretty, pretty destabilizing, you know, for someone like that,
but also transformative.
That's where the real benefit in those de-stabilizing I think so too well,
I've tell people I like getting paranoid from pot.
It's one of my favorite parts because when it's over, I feel good.
It's like a near death experience that you always survive.
It didn't happen. You're okay.
The lesson in it, that that fear comes with a lesson and that,
that insecurity comes with the lesson.
And I think part of the lesson is appreciate the moment of life,
appreciate life, appreciate this. Right. You know,
and when you're all up on, on pot, you know, everything's crazy.
Like when it's over, you can like right.
You relax and you can appreciate things in a different way. Right.
Episodes of the Joe Rogan experience are now free on Spotify. That's right.
They're free from September 1st to December 1st,
they're going to be available everywhere. But after December 1st,
they will only be available on Spotify, but they will be free.
That includes the video. The video will also be there. It'll also be free.
That's all we're asking. Go download Spotify, Bubba.
Okay.